even though he knows the end from the
beginning that doesn't
mean that somehow this implies that if
he gives you a certain command that
wasn't the ideal command that God wanted
his people to follow and then he
replaced with something better that
means see God didn't know no Jesus told
you why these commands were not the best
commands they were not evil commands but
they were not the best commands and even
those commands
they couldn't live up to and therefore
God came and gave them a better Covenant
because now Jesus says instead of me
stooping to your level I'm going to
elevate you to my level by the power of
the Holy
Spirit you got it
now yes yes yes okay now what does he
say about the law read Romans 7
7-4 What then shall we say that the law
is sin by no
means yet if it had not been for the law
I would not have known sin I would not
have known what it is to Cort if the law
had not said You shall not go but sin
seizing an opportunity through the
Commandment produced in me all kind of
covenants uh Co covetousness meaning
like Desiring things that you shouldn't
desire like you covet my hair because
you have
none thank you apart apart from the law
sin lies dead I was once alive apart
from the law but when the Commandment
came sin came alive and I died the very
Commandment that promised life proved to
be death for me or death to
me the law was
weak because the law could not Empower
you to Carri it out so the law actually
brought death because of your inability
to obey
so you see what he said I was alive when
I didn't know what the law was when the
law was revealed then sin arose in me
caused me to break it bringing death so
I died after I realized what the law was
and I had to obey it then I broke it and
breaking the law brings death this is
what Hebrews are saying it's not that
the law is bad it's that the law doesn't
give you the power to do it and because
the law doesn't give you the power to do
it you're weak and sinful you end up
breaking the law and bringing death even
though the purpose of the law was to
bring life because look what he says
about the law keep going for sin seizing
an opportunity through the Commandment
deceived me and though it killed me
through it not though through it killed
me through it killed me deceived me the
law was used to kill me not that the law
killed me but sin used the law to kill
me because sin knew if I break the law I
die so it caused me to break the law and
I died so now look what he says about
the law though look what he says so the
law is Holy and the Commandment is Holy
and the righteous and good does that
sound like he thinks the the law is evil
nope nope not at all okay keep reading
did that which is good then bring that
to me so if the law is good did it bring
death no it wasn't the law that brought
death it was sin that made me break the
law and sin brought death on me
absolutely and through the Commandment
might bring sinful Beyond may now let me
explain what he means here without the
law telling me what right or wrong is
then there is no sin sin is breaking the
law whether there's no law there's no
sin because there's no law for you to
break so he's saying when the law was
revealed that's When sin could
occur that's when I knew what sin is
that's when I knew you should not covet
that's when I knew you should not lie
that's when I knew you should not steal
that's why when I knew I should not take
the lord's name in vain that's when I
knew I have no other God the law
revealed it to me and now the law shows
how sinful I really am because I keep
breaking it though I don't want to break
it showing how desperately sick I am and
why I need a savior and someone to heal
me that's why the last verse look what
he says for we know that the law is
spiritual but I am of the flesh sold
under sin once sin Springs in action and
causes me to break the law and the more
I succumb to sin the weaker I become and
the stronger sin becomes over my life
leaving me powerless so that I need the
Holy Spirit to empower me and make me
alive because it requires someone of the
spirit to do the law because the law is
given to people born of the spirit to do
it is that what he says beautiful and
then the next one 1 Timothy 1 18:11 then
I'll show you Romans 8 how TI in this is
next one what he says here now we know
that the law is good it's what good is
so how can someone read Hebrew misread
Hebrews 8 to say that Paul is saying the
law is
bad if one uses it
lawfully understanding this that the law
is not laid down for the just but for
the Lawless and disobedient for the
ungodly and sinners for the Unholy and
profane for those who strike their
fathers and mothers for murderers the
sexual immoral men who practices
homosexuality enslavers you guys catch
it before we move on Paul says enslaving
people taking people captive taking
slaves is a
sin 1 110 and the law for liars
perjurers and whatever else is contrary
to the
sound okay in accordance with the
Glorious Gospel of the Blessed god with
which I have been entrusted now I got to
break this down guys this this is meat
glorify the holy spirit for being the
teacher may he use my mouth and we are
his disciples this is meat you're
getting why is Paul saying the law is
not for people who are holy and
righteous notice the law is given for
who the Lawless those who disregard the
law the disobedient ungodly who have no
fear of God who want to break God's
commands
those who are profane and those who beat
their parents and and are disrespectful
parents murderers sexually immoral
homosexuals so much for the Bible
allowing samesex marriage those who are
kidnappers who kidnap people enslave
them perjurers you know what he means by
that you know what he means this laws
for them let me explain you guys want me
to go a little
deep okay let me go a little deep for
the rest of you people who are righteous
do not need the law if you are righteous
you already do what is right in the
sight of God it's people who are wicked
and evil that need the law to constrain
them so there's no Anarchy what Paul is
saying is God gave the law for these
evil beasts these Wicked immoral beasts
who need to be warned that if they break
the law there's punishment in order to
use the fear of punishment to constrain
them so they don't act upon
it in other words wow so that now makes
sense connection with the Romans too now
you got it yeah so you got it now that
makes sense with Romans 2 Romans 2 was
always a mysterious thing for me the
first like 16 17 verses now that makes
sense so you got it now so what Paul is
saying let me explain it Mark you're
welcome that's why Mark I say you'll
find all your answers on my YouTube
channel and blog I've already answered
them just use the search engine so there
you go all right now let me get some as
you're thinking about it so you
understand what he's saying yes you are
if you are a pedophile and then the law
comes out whoever violates the child
will be killed because of that law that
will put fear in your heart not to act
on your pedophilia because you don't
want to get caught and
killed right right right that's why God
gave the law until you are born of the
spirit because then when you're born of
the spirit
you don't need the law to threaten you
with death or punishment because now
born of the spirit you Delight to make
Jesus happy and not break his heart
anymore Here For example just you and I
and may Jesus give us power to be pure
and I practice what I preach and may
Jesus never allow me to succumb America
says I can go and have sex with women
I'm living alone and may the Lord Jesus
protect us Lord purify us that I never
shame you never touch anyone
until I'm married if I get married your
will be done okay I'm alone America says
go have 50,000
girlfriends why do you think I don't go
and pick up a girl why do you think I
don't go
and try to find a girl to sleep with
every day of the week the law says I can
do it I'm not going to go to jail it's
because
Jesus changed me and Jesus revealed
himself to me how much he loves me and
how it hurts him and because I love
Jesus I don't want to hurt his heart
that's why I don't do it so I don't need
a telling me not to do it it's the love
of Jesus that compels me not to do it
because Jesus says I love you so much I
died for you will you now live for me
how will you now show your gratitude to
me you know I love you and I'm in love
with you and you know I died for you to
save you from your sin what's your
response to me will you continue to hurt
me or you going to continue now to show
me that you love me and are
thankful see the difference beautiful so
you born of the spirit you don't need
the law anymore because you don't want
to break the law not because you're
afraid of punishment but because you
love Jesus you don't want to hurt
him that's what Paul is saying
here see what Paul is saying here yes
sir that's his point so no Paul is not
saying the law is bad or the law is you
know you no that's not his point he's
saying though the law is not God's ideal
standard the law is still good it's
still holy it's still righteous and God
has made concessions that are not his
ideal in other words God has given you
one of two choices you can do either
choice and it's still good but doing
this one is better than the other for
example I'm GNA give you one example you
don't need to turn that I'll give you
the RSE and 1 Corinthians 7 6-9 Paul
says it's better that you don't get
married however
this is not a command it's a concession
you can get married because that's not
wrong getting married is not wrong but
it's better you don't so they're both
good but one is better than the
other this is what Jesus is saying
allowing you divorce that's not
necessarily
evil in some situations divorce is
better but it's not God's
ideal you understand the point now
absolutely absolutely absolutely now let
me show you what Paul meant in Hebrews 8
that the law that God found there was
something weak in it why because Romans
83 there's your answer Romans
83 read it Romans 7 Romans chapter 8
verse three all right let's read the
third I think this highlighted will be
for God has done what the law weakened
by the flesh there you go
could not do so Jesus did for
you by coming to die in your place to
pay your debt of sin and then Empower
you by the spirit because the law could
not bring you life because your flesh
was so weak that you end up breaking the
law so Jesus did what the law could not
do the law could not give you life
because your flesh made you too weak to
do it so Jesus had to come and give you
life
amen so you see what he means that there
was a weakness in the law because the
law could not give you life why because
it's bad no because you're bad you're
evil and the law doesn't give you the
ability to do it it tells you what to do
what not to do and God says do what I
tell you to do and avoid things I tell
you not to do because I want you to live
but because your flesh is weak you end
up breaking it bringing death that's
what makes the law weak because it
didn't give you life even though God
wanted to live but because of your flesh
you broke the law and brought death so
Jesus came to do for you what the law
could not do pay your debt of sin give
you life and the strength of the Holy
Spirit to
walk in victory over your flesh that's
what it
says amen amen